- Sometimes I'm able
to do a lot of research
before going to a place,
and sometimes I have to just wing it.
Here's what I know.
Every year, this town, Honiton in
south-west England,
has a tradition where they
throw hot pennies off balconies
down onto waiting crowds
who try to catch them.
Apparently, this started
more than 700 years ago
as part of the local fair.
Back then, the pennies
would be scalding hot.
And part of the entertainment,
at least for the people throwing,
was watching poor people
burn themselves
as they scrambled to
pick up the pennies.
Back then, pennies were
worth a lot more,
very roughly, it'd be
the equivalent
of throwing £1 coins
off a balcony,
so perhaps worth minor burns
if you're desperate?
Seven centuries later,
they do still throw pennies.
But I'm assured they're
not scalding,
just merely warm.
And that is all I know.
My script ends here,
but I'm hoping I can find out more
from the folks who run it
and also not get injured
by flying pennies.
- This is my first Hot Pennies
as the Mayor of Honiton.
I've been coming to
Hot Pennies all my life.
It's led predominantly by
the town crier.
It's his event, if you like,
and I'm gatecrashing it.
- I'm the town crier and
mace bearer of Honiton.
I've held this position for 27 years
and today, the Hot Pennies Ceremony
will be my 28th.
We toss pennies from balconies, windows
and if you're brave enough
to scramble for them,
pick them off the floor,
they're all yours to take home.
- People are pretty much
sorting themselves out by height
so the kids are going to the front.
The adults are coming to the back.
I hope they're going to be okay.
I hope I'm going to be okay!
- I've been on the committee,
believe it or not, for 46 years,
and this is my 47th Honiton Hot Pennies.
When Honiton was granted a Royal Charter,
they held a fair and of course,
they wanted people to come into
the town to make it a success,
but quite a lot of those people
hadn't paid their landlords their rent
so it was decided that they would
give an amnesty during fair week.
And whilst the glove was hoisted,
no man will be arrested.
- [SHOUTS] No man shall be arrested.
- [CROWD CHANTS] No man shall be arrested.
- I've only just thought to bring
something to catch the pennies
and it's far too late.
Like, there's people with
upside down umbrellas,
there's kids with buckets,
and I, uh...
wish me luck.
- Honiton is famous as
one of the staging points
on the Exeter to London Road,
and there were more pubs
on Honiton High Street
than most towns have.
There were wealthy people
who lived in the town
and who stayed in the inns
and they used to take delight
in throwing out hot pennies
and watching the serfs, I suppose,
burn their fingers.
- Here we go.
Bloody hell!
Oh!
Augh! Ow.
I took my eye off the pennies
for a moment.
- It's 802 years, this year. We think.
There would've been a few breaks
over the years for World War whatever.
For years, it's run on nothing
because all the pennies are
collected in jars in the pubs
and we do throw out
hundreds and hundreds of
pounds' worth of pennies.
- All the pubs would have a large bottle
or a can or a tray
and people would put
their loose change in it.
Nowadays you have to order the pennies
two weeks in advance from the banks
to even have them.
- Come on!
It's one penny.
It's one penny, but I'm really
proud of the penny.
Can confirm, slightly warm.
- They used to be heated up.
They were literally heated
in the ovens of the pubs.
There was a stream running down
one of the sides of the high street.
So there's photographs of kids
in the drains pulling pennies out,
but also cooling them
because they've got burns on their hands.
And I believe there's a lady in Honiton
who, to this day, carries a scar
from being burnt by a
penny in the mid-'60s.
- They used to be proper hot,
I mean, burning, scalding hot,
and if you caught them on your arm,
I do have a friend from school
and he claims that he still has a scar
and he's really proud
of his Hot Pennies scar.
But they'd be scattering on the floor
and it would hurt to pick them up.
- They've got a kid throwing up there
and he's very much
throwing at, and not...
...augh! and not up.
- We used to wear gloves,
hobnail boots, old clothes
and then when we got back in school,
we'd given 100 yards for skiving off.
- It seems crazy now
that we used to get
tossed boiling hot coins
especially when we were
little young children.
But to be honest, that was half the fun!
- I'm well out of range here.
I did not fight hard enough to be
in the crowd with the umbrellas.
I'm going to cut my losses
with two pennies
and one slightly injured camera operator,
I'm so sorry!
- It was quite a wild event.
Nowadays we have to have
a little bit more careful
so the pennies are scattered
rather than thrown.
They're warmed in the sun
at best,
or at worst depending on
where you look at it.
We hope we don't have injuries.
We're about making certain that
these wonderful old
quaint customs continue.